gérard larcher bonjour bonjour est venu
au bistrot du théâtre je vous en prie
gérard larcher président du sénat merci
devenu donc jusqu'ici automne au bistrot
du sénateur des yvelines sénateurs sans
mandat que vous appréciez
particulièrement parce que la première
élection c'est 1986 1997 vous en devenez
le vice-président et 2008 pour la
première fois un président qu'est ce qui
vous plaît tant dans cette fonction de
sénateur d'abord c'est le racisme ans
dans le territoire
c'est la relation avec les élus locaux
pendant 31 ans j'ai été élu de la ville
de rambouillet je pense que le
territoire la proximité c'est quelque
chose d'essentiel notamment en ce moment
où en ces temps de crise et de désarroi
on sent que l'élu qui a la confiance des
citoyens le seul d'ailleurs à la voir de
manière majoritaire c'est le maire le
maire adjoint conseiller municipal parce
que je dis aussi les dans la vie des
gens il est apportée d'engueulades au
ciné vous l'avez dire il est dans le
contact direct en 2008 lorsque vous
devenez un président fort a pour la
première fois vous disiez que le sénat
devait être la maison des élus locaux
justement s'adresser puis troisième
raison c'est qu'on bêta qui lisait ses
grands conseils des communes de france
monde et on l'a vu il ya peu au moment
de la loi sur la nouvelle organisation
territoriale de la république le sinaï
pas simplement la majorité du sénat a
tenu à quoi a conservé la commune comme
cellule de base de la démocratie locale
a tenu à garder le département comme une
proximité sociale et territoriale
parce que nous voyons bien sûr la tâche
était à ma permanence à rambouillet j'ai
reçu un agriculteur qui était en même
temps qu'au ciné municipal et il me
disait le sentiment que la technocratie
haut niveau et elle devrait pouvoir et
qu'il fallait que les élus se
réapproprient la vie quotidienne des
gens mais les élus locaux qui ont besoin
d'être entendus
on l'a vu avec la baisse des dotations
vous étiez mobilisés à leurs côtés
d'ailleurs ils sont inquiets tous et
tous ces mets résoudre en compte sont
acquis à la fois il se rendra compte
qu'il faut participer à l'effort de
redressement des finances du pays
mais là c'est trouver c'est brutal c'est
dans un calendrier ou en même temps va
conduire sans débat préalable nous en
concertation une réforme de la dotation
globale de fonctionnement c'est quoi
pour vous téléspectateurs
c'est ce que l'état donne à chaque
commune et ça va baisser d'environ 30%
c'est ça c'est 30% et parfois plus en
fonction des communes parce qu'on parle
beaucoup de dgf on oublie la péréquation
et nous sommes dans les jv dans un
territoire qui est beaucoup plus y aune
et outils nous la péréquation
péréquation ce sont ces communes qui
sont pas dire un peu plus aisés qui
peuvent aider en priorité
quasiment toutes les communes des
yvelines qui sont sollicités but ce sont
aussi des communes qui ont su construire
un cadre de vie ou le reconstruire je
pense un certain nombre de communes qui
connaissent ou ont connu notamment des
quartiers en grande difficulté
je reviens juste sur votre parcours vous
l'avez dit vous avez été maire de
rambouillet ça ne peut pas l'oublier
conseiller régional d'ile-de-france
ministres aussi le gouvernement de jean
pierre raffarin puis celui de dominique
de villepin c'est poste ne vous ont pas
laissé le même souvenir que celui de
sénateur justement j'en reviens vous
prenez réagir vous pouvez poste de
ministre du travail
là aussi vous êtes dans le concret vous
êtes dans la vie des gens et parfois la
vie difficile des gens quand une
entreprise ferme
vous avez à gérer
j'allais dire les réalités sociales les
réalités économiques de cette fermeture
c'est un poste de l'humain aussi mais je
dois dire que l'humain il commence pour
moi sur le territoire aussi et c'est
vraiment le sens de mon engagement
mais je pense que quand tu crois
profondément la nécessité deux chambres
notamment pu la réforme a plaqué n'a
dans la république on le voit bien on
est plus totalement dans une position
d'arbitré
on le voit bien au cours des bugs
lakanal et je pense indispensable qu'il
y ait une chance qu'il soit élu
immédiatement après l'élection
présidentielle pour exprimer une autre
une vision du territoire c'est le cas du
sénat vous avez utilisé le mot de
d'humains humains être proche des
électeurs ça c'est quelque chose qui est
qui qui vous tient particulièrement à
coeur va peut-être préciser parce
qu'avant de faire de la politique
bon j'ai pas une formation de politique
on va dire cette vétérinaire j'étais
vétérinaire shit et aussi le 14 ans et
oui mais j'étais aussi un militant
gaulliste engagé très jeune père était
élu d'une commune rurale hébert et j'ai
été élevé au lait quand même de
l'engagement très proche des chevaux
passé oui c'est votre passion alors pour
l'anecdote vous avez fait partie sur
frayeur de ma part de l'équipe de france
le sport équestre
j'ai vu par phil lord et géo de 76 à
montréal d'abord j'ai accompagné comme
tout et rynair l'équipe de france
pendant près de
huit années dans beaucoup de
championnats en fait vous faut bien
avoir en tête que je suis d'origine
normande terre du cheval et que j'ai
commencé ma carrière comme militaires
dans le cadre du service national
aspirant au régiment de cavalerie de la
garde républicaine
j'ai vu beaucoup de stages dans les
haras nationaux et que vraiment c'était
mon engagement sur le territoire qui n'a
pas exclu que je fasse aussi des besoins
notamment dans ma normandie dans le
cadre de remplacement et sur les jeux
olympiques de 76 parce que c'est tout de
même une médaille d'or en solo six ans
médaille d'or au saut d'obstacles
marianne epin 26 ans médaille d'or par
équipe aux côtés de très grands
cavaliers nos pompes en allait de la
mise en forme de l'équipe
c'est un beau souvenir c'est un
merveilleux souvenir là le souvenir
cette marseillaise dans le stade
olympique de montréal
on avait entendu qu'une seule fois mille
ruses 110 m e v et nous c'était un
moment à moi qui crois profondément à
mon pays
moi qui crois profondément que mon pays
c'est un pays qui a un message donné
quand vous avez 26 ans vous entendez la
marseillaise et vous êtes là au milieu
du stade
quelque part il se passe quelque chose
en vous gérard si on va poursuivre la
discussion va s installer en salle je
vous laisse passer juste devant qui je
vous suis allé
vers la relation poursuit la discussion
avec avec vous on continue à parler de
vos engagements et puis il ya de
l'actualité aussi l'actualité du moment
c'est l'accueil des réfugiés ce qu'il
faut des quotas est ce qu'il faut fermer
les frontières comme certains de nos
voisins l'ont fait en europe
d'abord je crois qu'il ya une espèce de
confusion tout ce qui relève du droit
d'asile doivent pouvoir bénéficier des
dispositions de la convention de genève
qui date de 1951 et l'a utilisé le terme
de quotas n'a pas de sens puisque nous
devons examiner chaque dossier et voir
s'ils relèvent de la ville s'il ne
relève pas de l'asile ils doivent être
reconduit s'il relève de l'asile ils
doivent être accueillis protégé pour
sans doute repartir une fois que les
conditions politiques des conditions de
sécurité seront retrouvés dans les pays
dont ils viennent je pense
particulièrement la syrie ou ou à l'irak
qui d'ailleurs aura besoin de ses
compétences là pour se reconstruire
et puis les phénomènes migratoires la
migration économique il ya pas que
l'europe d'ailleurs secrétaire général
de l ocde angel gurria disait il y a peu
qui à 60 millions de migrants
actuellement des femmes des enfants des
hommes en afrique ce qui se passe au
nigeria ce qui se passe en afrique du
sud
toute cette réalité là il faut la
prendre en compte quand vous entendez
est donc un l'agile bien sûr ça fait
partie de nos valeurs
et quand j'utilise le terme cottage les
utiliser dans un rapport au président de
la république le 15 avril dernier
c'était un sujet qui n'était pas
d'actualité brûlante même si déjà la
situation dans la méditerranée on l'a
oublié qu'ils avaient les images des
rimes
mais elle n'avait pas eu le même effet
déclencheur et moi même j'avais
rencontré le procureur de catane en
sicile et le
directeur de la police de l'air et des
frontières italien mais je dois dire que
pour l'immigration il faut une politique
de l'immigration et j'ai proposé qu'elle
soit une politique d'immigration qui
fixe des quotas
c'est là où il faut bien faire la
distinction des mots après un débat au
parlement
c'est je crois la responsabilité d'un
pays de conduire sa politique
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'a nomme plutôt de
tradition de gauche comte sponville me
disait quand il est venu me rencontrer
pour la préparation de ce rapport
mais quand vous entendez tout le monde
marine le pen dire que comparer cette
invasion migratoire à celle du 4e siècle
que ça aura peut-être les mêmes
conséquences qu'il faudrait instaurer
dans des considérations historiques
vous savez nous ont fait le coup au mois
de juillet où ils nous ont déclaré que
c'était les vaudois qui était dangereux
souvenez vous dans le détail en provence
et n'a rien dit tenir à dole c'était
naturellement les vaudois qui était
coupable donc les prendre pour référence
historique
si en tous les cas pas mes références
l'extrême droite c'est à des styles pour
moi pour moi c'est le contraire des
valeurs de la france et je le dis à ceux
qui peuvent être tentés je les comprends
du sentiment de se dire mais aller
toutes ces parties que nous connaissons
classique d'alternance au fond ils ont
fait quoi
ils nous répondent us qui répondent à
nos problématiques mais que ce soit au
plan économique que ce soit au plan des
valeurs le front national n'apporte
aucune réponse aucune réponse il ne vit
que sur la haine et je dois dire que
c'est pas dans la haine de l'autre qu'on
progressera même si personnellement je
pense qu'il ya des dossiers qu'il faut
avoir le courage d'aborder j'allais dire
avec courage en refusant la langue de
bois et les hommes politiques
d'aujourd'hui auront du courage
justement votre mentor c'était vous
adhérez en 76 au rpr votre mentor c'est
écrit à l'époque c'était général de
gaulle parce que en fait j'ai commencé
très tôt
à l'union des jeunes pour le progrès à
l'union démocratique du travail
j'étais en classe de première es et moi
je crois à la fois rôle d'un état qui
est un des balanciers stabilisateur de
la société qui représente mon pays qui
incarne des valeurs et cette référence
n'est pas une nostalgie
nous avons écrit un livre collectif il
ya deux ans qui a eu récemment un prix
le prix d'ailleurs de l'egypte et qui
dit le gaullisme une solution pour
demain c'est quoi de dire que la nation
cinq sens que dire que les problèmes de
la nation il faut qu'on les règle est de
dire que toutes nos valeurs repose
d'abord sur la primauté de l'humain
c'est autour de ça que je me retrouve
on va reparler du sénat si vous le
voulez bien une somme allés faire un
petit micro-trottoir est allé demander
aux gens ce qu'ils pensaient tout
simplement du sénat je vous laisse
écouter au quelle image avez-vous du
sénat senate n'a semblé donc deux
personnes qui sont là pour pour
travailler sur nos lois notamment voilà
dans notre démocratie
moi je vous important d'avoir deux
assemblée nationale sénat les sénateurs
ont un rôle extrêmement important
malheureusement ils dorment parfois en
séance où ils sont pas là des baux
dormeurs quand on regarde un peu comment
ça se passe de films ici qui est un bon
coup qu'ils dorment
d'abord ils sont très âgés et puis en
fin de compte bon il ya un aller retour
entre à l'assemblée nationale et sénat
c'est toujours l'assemblée cas le
dernier mot donc en fin de compte le
sénat y sert à rien il brosse à l'image
de deux plutôt de nous anciens géré par
nos anciens quoi bon peut-être un peu
péjoratif mais voilà l'utilité je vois
pas trop ce que sa part au cnra ça
revient en deuxième lecture donc pas
dire que ça sert à rien mais presque
voilà les gens sont durs un oui est ce
qu'ils sont dans le vrai à la fois
secondeur citoyenne que vous avez
interrogé des reconnaissent le rôle lui
c'est dans la fabrication de la loi il
ya des poncifs et c'est pas facile de
les changer
le sénat serait vieux en fait très peu
de différence avec des assemblées
nationales 4,5 à d et ceci est
l'héritage très vieux concept parce qu'à
mon époque quand j'ai commencé fallait
avoir au moins 35 ans pour être élu au
ce et la salle est plus cas aujourd'hui
mais naturellement les choses se mettent
en place progressivement sur la présence
au sénat c'est comparable l'assemblée
nationale vous savez qu'à partir du
début de ce mois les sénateurs ont des
obligations d'engagement c'est vous qui
l'avez souhaité évoquer entre autres en
avant le fait qu'elle avait secrètement
aussi ça faisait partie de mon projet
pour le sénat j'ai été élu là dessus
parce que je pense que par exemple il ya
des moments solennels
quand on vote sur des grands textes
quand on l'entend avant le vote les
explications de vote quand on travaille
en commission
c'est le moment où le sénateur doit
donner son avis personnellement c'est
aussi le moment par exemple quand on
contrôle le gouvernement des questions
d'actualité et à partir du mois
d'octobre
c'est pas une fois tous les quinze jours
mais chaque semaine que les sénat contre
leur gouvernement
alors ne sert à rien c'est pas vrai
nouvelle organisation territoriale de la
république qui a préservé la commune
mais qui à le dire c'est nous qui
l'avons eue dernier mot c'est nous
puisque nous avons fait un compromis
c'est un des plus grands textes depuis
le début de ce quinquennat
souvenez-vous françois hollande et
manuel valls avait annoncé la
disparition du département avait annoncé
que et dans les communautés y aurait le
suffrage universel
nous avons pensé qu'en ces temps de
crise c'était très important la commune
et que le département s'était pas
ringard et que les allers retours du
gouvernement qui avait supprimé remis la
compétence générale
tout ça n'avait pas de sens je vais
prendre un autre exemple la loi macron
pas par le temps et députés l'ont jamais
voté 49 3 qu'est ce qui enrichit le
texte pour les entreprises c'est la
troisième texte la loi sur le
renseignement doit très importante pour
lutter contre le terrorisme
qu'est ce qui a apporté la garantie des
libertés individuelles
le président du conseil constitutionnel
qui le dit c'est le sénat voyez sur
trois exemples sur trois exemples bien
sûr en dernière lecture le sénat et peut
ne pas avoir le dernier mot
63% des amendements du sénat au cours de
la dernière année ont été adoptés même
en cas de désaccord je pense qu'au
contraire du fait du quinquennat du fait
que l'élection législative et la
réplique sismique de l'élection
présidentielle on a besoin de ces dames
c'est mon rôle c'est ce que chez
d'expliquer que le sénat est utile à la
démocratie que c'est un balancier
stabilisateur et dans un pays où les
territoires ruraux les petites villes
ont le sentiment d'être oubliés
le sénat a une responsabilité
représentation particulièrement grande
la rentrée c'est en ce moment pour le
pour les sénateurs justement vos
priorités pour cette nouvelle nouvelle
année nouvelle session parlementaire
mettre en oeuvre les réformes d'abord la
manière de légiférer c'est extrêmement
important a porté sur le texte migration
c'est pas texte de circonstance il est
dans les tuyaux depuis des mois et des
mois les réponses à l'aune de ce que
nous voyons est ce que nous observons
dans la crise migratoire actuelle
et puis expliquer et dire que par
exemple le retour à l'équilibré qui est
indispensable pour notre budget ça passe
par la confiance faite dans les
entreprises y aura pas de croissance
si on fait pas confiance aux entreprises
nous voyons bien les chiffres du chômage
annoncée il ya quelques jours sur des
chiffres catastrophiques
on aura bientôt un million de chômeurs
de plus reparti à la hausse et restent
immenses sommes au début de ce
quinquennat
et ça c'est le premier des maux dont
souffre notre société savez moi je
continue à tenir une permanence et je
suis dans une ville qui connaît pas le
plein emploi mais rambouillet c'est un
peu comme ici on a plutôt le
plein-emploi premier les sujets dont
viennent nous parler nos concitoyens
c'est l'emploi parce que il n'ya pas une
seule famille dans ce pays qui n'est un
membre de sa famille qui connaissent le
chômage chômage de longue durée
il n'y a pas de familles où les jeunes
ne sont pas en grande difficulté pour
leur premier emploi parce que le sauna
spa de solution miracle
mettez moi j'ai été un ministre du
travail qui a vu le chômage décroître
est ce que c'était que jenny de borloo
et de l'arche est sans doute le génie de
jean louis borloo qu'à un vrai ami mais
surtout ça a été un moment on a eu de la
croissance
on était à 3 presque 3% on décrète pas à
sa naissance mais non on crée les
conditions et pour sa confiance aux
entreprises
il va falloir revoir la question du coût
du travail dans ce pays il va falloir
revoir la question de l'organisation du
travail vous savez je suis quelqu'un qui
a cru 20 ans qu'on pouvait partager le
travail c'était une erreur
il va falloir venir maintenant à ce que
ça soit au niveau de l'entreprise ou de
la branche qu'on discute temps de
travail organisation de l'entreprise
politique politicienne cette fois s'il
ya des élections dans trois mois il y
aura des élections ces élections
régionales
- troyes - oui mais oui ça sera au tout
début du mois de décembre cette question
les républicains ont-ils fait oublier
l'ump avant que vous me donniez votre
réponse écoutez ce qu'en pensent les
gens dans la rue à saint quentin en
yvelines
on a changé l'étiquette à le packaging
mais ce qui est dedans c'est toujours le
même je pense donc j'y crois pas trop en
fait
voilà républicains y voient là on a
voulu changer d'image pour redorer le
blason mais ça fait pas tout non je
pense que non ça le fait pas comment la
vie non pour moi ya pas ton âme je n'ais
pas vraiment écouté les actualités
concernant république aux derniers temps
mais bon voilà peut-être y aura du sang
neuf peut-être oui grâce à nicolas
sarkozy c'est exactement pareil qu'avant
et je dirais même je sais même pas si
c'est pas pire pour moi c'est kif kif
complètement pareil y'a pas de soucis et
ils ont en plus fait des frais
extraordinaires pour changer de cible
je trouve que c'est pas forcément utile
dans notre période même si vous vous
dites quoi on vous dit heureusement
nicolas sarkozy est revenu ou monter
leur mieux fait de s'abstenir
tout le monde sait que j'étais réservé
sur le changement de nom je pense que ce
qui compte plus que le nom c'est le
contenu collectif qu'on va apporter aux
républicains et c'est le socle commun de
valeurs sur lequel nous devons nous
retrouver et on va avoir de temps le
temps d'un parti politique qui s'est
réorganisée et chacun connaît ma liberté
vis-à-vis des colas sarkozy il n'a plus
tôt fait de le travail
enfin depuis son élection et puis nous
devons nous mobiliser là pour les
élections régionales est ici
naturellement moi qui préside le comité
de soutien pour l'ile-de-france à
valérie pécresse
je pense qu' il est temps il est temps
de mettre fin à une politique régionale
invisible sans substance sans colonne
vertébrale l'un des sujets majeurs qui
sont les infrastructures de transport
par exemple il ya des sujets majeurs sur
la question des lycées il ya les sujets
majeurs
dont l'accompagnement de politiques
territoriales à l'université pour la
recherche avec les nouvelles compétences
des régions et tout ça il va falloir le
régler et puis pour les républicains il
y aura le temps des primaires c'est un
temps où chacun va pouvoir sur un socle
commun de valeurs présenter son projet
et je le rappelle c'est pas simplement
les militants qui choisiront c'est tous
ceux dans les électeurs qui se
reconnaissent autour des valeurs du
centre de la droite des gaullistes pour
qu'ils s'expriment sera lieu en novembre
et c'est pas réservé aux militants
politiques je crois qu'il faut que nous
rentrions dans une phase je le disais il
ya quelques jours aux journées
parlementaires qui se tenait à reims des
républicains je disais méfions nous de
nos victoires liée à l'échec de la
gauche
il faut que nos victoires soit
l'adhésion à nos valeurs avec nos amis
du centre
c'est en tous les cas ma démarche que
les citoyens se posent la question en
disant c'est que du packaging
à nous de faire que dans packaging
nouveau les produits non pas nouveau
mais allez des propositions qui entraîne
l'adhésion et l'engagement des citoyens
justement est ce que la droite le centre
droit vous êtes sur de bons rails par
rapport à cette proposition à ses
propositions de programmes
visiblement le point.fr qui relaie cette
information il ya moins d'adhérents
aujourd'hui à jour de cotisation aux
républicains qu'il n'y en avait l'année
dernière à la même date à l'ump quelques
milliers si j'ai bien lu mais alors que
l'objectif de nicolas sarkozy c'était de
faire avancer que font naturellement
qu'on réenchanter la politique et on le
voit bien devant la tentation comme
beaucoup de jeunes soit de ne plus voter
soit voter pour les extrêmes et
notamment le front national ça veut dire
que nous il va falloir que dans notre
projet et nous dialoguons avec les
citoyens que nous répondions autour des
valeurs qui sont les nôtres nous croyons
d'abord la nation le croyons que la
richesse
viendra de l'entreprise nous croyons que
c'est elle qui créera les emplois mais
en même temps il faut avoir un projet
social et ce projet social nous devons
aujourd'hui la juste et nous devons
savoir comment nous allons financer tout
cela nous avons aussi une place de notre
pays en europe
aujourd'hui on ne présente que l'europe
dans ses difficultés voir ses échecs
la question migratoire montre bien que
la question de schengen g appartenait à
la commission du sénat qui a examiné
schengen avant 95
c'était tout jeune sénateur toutes ces
sujets sont devant nous il faut qu'on
ait un projet ce projet des citoyens
arbitreront et puis ensuite celui qui
sera notre candidat
on le conduire à la victoire ferait
quand même remarquer que lyon une
période difficile
en fait les promesses de françois
hollande n'ont pas été tenues et la plus
terrible de ses promesses non tenues
c'est l'inversion de la courbe du
chômage
il a dit qu'il ne se représenterait pas
sinon ils rasent acte de bonne
conscience à ce moment-là et de
responsabilité mais c'est quand même un
engagement qu'il a pris à la légère
au fond je regarde l autre jour ces deux
de ses émissions avant l'élection et
notamment au 22e tour que d'engagements
non tenus que d'engagements non tenus
et comment voulez vous que les citoyens
derrière croit aux engagements
politiques et c'est ce que j'ai dit aux
journées parlementaires à nous de
reconquérir la confiance des citoyens
nous l'avons pas encore j'en suis
parfaitement conscient et si souvent je
cite que seuls les maires ont la
confiance majoritaire les français vont
peut-être nous inspirer de cette
proximité là une toute dernière question
concernant justement cette cette
primaire à droite dans quinze jours à
votre place jean frédéric poisson sera
l'invité de cette émission café
politique député benoist président du
parti chrétien-démocrate ce que vous
connaissez bien puisqu'il a été maire
de rambouillet à partir de 2000 été
pendant longtemps conseiller municipal
puis oui produira des premières ensuite
il était vraiment aimé castres un petit
mot pour lui puisqu'il est candidat à
cette primaire parce qu'à garçons qui
portent vraie valeur c'est un garçon qui
est je dois dire d'une loyauté parfaite
à méditer quand on dit que les
politiques ne seraient pas loyaux quand
j'ai cessé d'être ministre à la fin du
quinquennat de jacques chirac
le lendemain il m'a dit mais c'est vous
qui devait redevenir maire puisque on se
vouvoie toujours vouvoyé etc pour yachts
et est vraiment une qualité
chacun connaît son intelligente nous ne
sommes pas tout à fait dans la même
formation politique
il a pris une décision qui lui
appartient
pour faire valoir un certain nombre de
ces idées moi je suis dans la commission
d'organisation des primaires un peu le
sage moi je veux des primaires loyal je
veux des primaires équitable je veux des
primaires qui soit l'occasion d'un
véritable débat pour que enfin et c'est
un élément très important pour
reconquérir la confiance des citoyens
que ce soit l'occasion des changes et
pas simplement d'investissement et les
petites phrases jouer ça ça ne passionne
pas du tout et je pense que nos
compatriotes en ont marre c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'une partie du
micro-trottoir révèle et moi je
considère pas même quand les questions
ne sont pas très sympathique notamment
les vieux sénateur qui dormiraient quand
je les rassure je dors la nuit
brièvement et je peux simplement dire
à vos téléspectateurs il ya beaucoup de
travail qui est fait au sénat ike
actuellement par exemple sur la question
migratoire
il ya de vraies réflexions conduites des
poids depuis des mois au sénat
qu'actuellement même si saint quentin en
yvelines c'est moins une actualité sur
la question agricole qui derrière c'est
la filière agroalimentaire d'ailleurs
près de 13 % des emplois dans ce pays
le sénat a entrepris depuis des mois la
nécessaire réflexion parce que nous
étions la première puissance ya dix ans
exportatrices en europe en
agroalimentaire nous sommes et 3e
aujourd'hui à méditer quand on parle
travail emploi chômage et place de la
france merci gérard merci d'avoir invité
à servir